die fallen immer wieder wege ein wenig
auf neue arten und weisen essen
bestellen kann heute habe ich mir
gedacht ich verstehe einfach mal das
teuerste bei verschiedenen restaurants
diese werde ich allerdings auch zufällig
aus das ist eigentlich schon die ganze
sache ich war einmal in einem restaurant
oder in mehreren restaurants und hat
dort von der karte das teuerste bestellt
heute aber das ganze so ich habe auch
wirklich vor weshalb wir direkt loslegen
sollten also einmal scrollen
runter und wo liegt man daumen auf die
fette kuh das ist sehr sehr geil also
ihr wisst bestimmt fette kuh macht sehr
stabile bürger ihr seht ihr einen
letzten bestellung also ist es kein
neuer lagen für mich aber ich habe nicht
mal eine ahnung was da das teuerste ist
die salate werden es nicht sein unter
den bürgern könnte was sein 12 18 euro
400 gramm mit karamellisierten zwiebeln
salat tomaten doppeltem chili ketchup
und die chance also er hat in sich
bezahlt
19 euro für 1 400 gramm rindfleisch denn
das von einer guten qualität ist kostet
das natürlich auch seinen preis
sonderwünsche keine gas stufe auf jeden
fall nicht an sondern
maxity hinzufügen ich glaube es auch bei
400 kräfte dann würde ich sagen schicke
ich die bestellung raus dann gucken wir
nach zwei weiteren bestellen nummer eins
ist draußen jetzt heißt es ein weiteres
restaurant finden und dort crawler
einmal runter es sind wohl rund im hoch-
und nachts und engels die
bürgergesellschaft drehen noch mal könig
noch im burger bestellen und
rahmenball paket zu köln aber welt also
ich liebe halt rahmen in letzter zeit
lässt sich so gerne rahmen haben wir
keinen löffel hier ich gehe mal davon
aus dass hier das teuerste rahmen sein
werden aber in welcher konfiguration ist
hier die große frage wieso blieb also am
liebsten esse ich nie so rahmen schaaf
im restaurant aber die sind scheinbar
nicht die teuersten wieso butter mais
koriander tanten 15 euro pro rica rahmen
15 euro pro tier ii show you run auf 15
euro kommt da noch mehr weiter bittet es
nichts neues rahmenwerk 25 euro mit 15
euro ist das teuerste auf der karte
jetzt würde ich sagen kann ich nur aus
den 15 euro das haus suchen worauf der
meisten boxer auf jeden fall nämlich
rahmen unter den rahmen haben wir 12 3
der zufall will dass ich die theorie
kara rahmen bestelle tatsächlich damit
kagel amos sprossen glory und laub in
soja brühl das klingt hart alter zu
bestellen hinzufügen machen anmerkten
dort nahmen gerne bisschen schade das
ist wieder so ein video ich sehe da
wieder hier bestellt drei messen und wir
stellen einen sonderbeitrag ich
vielleicht was mein job ist aber das
bestellen jetzt und dann suchen wir
nummer zwei ihr seht an der seite zwei
bestellungen sind schon raus und jetzt
brauchen wir noch ein drittes restaurant
weil ich habe ein sehr hoch wir essen
mit dem gesamten büro natürlich diese
ganzen sachen auf aber ab geht die wilde
post einmal kräftig nach oben einmal
kräftig nach unten bis er nach oben
und wilmar wunder gerichte aus der
heimat neu interpretiert klingt erstmal
nicht verkehrt wenn 50 sehe ich hier ich
gucke noch gar nicht was es ist
23 eur 90 original wiener schnitzen
alter ich habe aber ernst bock darauf
hoffentlich es ist halt ein gutes wiener
schnitzel der das safe das teuerste auf
der karte kurzer prozess ich würde sagen
wiener schnitzel ballern wir uns noch
hinterher
also ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen das
ist schlecht ist aber das sind halt
nicht nach dem original wiener schnitzel
aus wenigstens sieht einen raschen
hausmannskost schnitzel aus
kartoffelsalat oder trüffel pommes dazu
griff accounts vier euro extra
kartoffelsalat ich muss keine addons
reinmachen ja dann zur drei bestellungen
sind raus wir warten das ganze jetzt ab
dauert bestimmt so eine halbe stunde
aber habt jetzt schon so einen hunger
ich wünschte ich hätte schon gegen west
zu essen kleinigkeit
das ist das denn ein kilogramm bio kost
chips von code fünf mal 50 bio satan ist
ja genau das was ich mir gerade
gewünscht habe noch mal für euch 5 max 5
ist mein code bei corot verpackungen
diesem tüte cocos chips aus lotto ist
kein zucker da ist nichts dran die kasse
durch so wegstecken so sommer ich
bestelle gab es zum dritten mal oder so
das einfach so ein geiler
vielschichtiger schnecken seiten trinkt
und esse ich jetzt auch noch spaß
beiseite leute damit mache ich mir jetzt
möglich wie gesagt komm 5 max 5 findet
ihr auch immer alles in der beschreibung
krieg 5 prozent aber eure bestellung der
coro und sprüche aus wir sehen uns
wieder wenn das essen da ist bei 123
bestellen sind angekommen ist mir
relativ schnell und ich war ja auch
gestärkt das hat es hat gar kein problem
wir fangen in der gleichen reihenfolge
an in der wir bestellt haben mit dem
mörder bürger erstmal 1890 ich habe
gedacht das kommt vielleicht sogar so
eine krassere box irgendwie sowas
special mäßiges aber wir gucken mal rein
weil das ist ja das ist der inhalt ja ok
vorher da ist sogar so bratensoße ein
was dabei das ist definitiv eine ansage
ich habe wirklich nicht den entlasten
schimmer wie man das essen sollte du
kannst ja schlecht den bürger raus
nehmen also die unterseite vom band ist
ja wahrscheinlich komplett sorry
soll ich einfach machen
das 2 1 18 eur 90 bürger ist meine ich
kenne und ich liebe die fette kuh aber
das hier auch hübschen waffenschein das
ding liegt auch wirklich so schwer in
der hand aber das brot ist nicht so
aufgeweicht wie man dachte wirklich
nicht ich bin sehr gespannt auf die gas
stufe das fleisch also dass auch
wirklich nur was für leute die den tag
über überhaupt nichts mehr vorhanden
[Musik]
habe ich keinen kleinen kopf einen
kleinen hund teilen klein aber das ist
unmöglich zu essen also erste sache die
man aber sagen muss fleisch ist medium
ja vielleicht schnee hat eine schöne
rosa farbe nicht dass er sich jetzt um
bringt ne
gut aus schon wir wirklich aussehe es
geht nicht anders also das ist einfach
durch einen klasse war aber so von
genuss dinge her ist mir das zu viel
fleisch also schmeckst du einfach nichts
anderes mehr
aber auch wenn ihn zu essen kostet
natürlich seinen preis wenn man so viel
rindfleisch drauf hat die fertigungs und
jungem fleisch aber von der kreation her
muss für mich nicht so viel draußen
trotzdem mal lustig das probiert sagte
reck war hält zu ihm selbst ja gut dann
kann ich schon machen dies aber noch
nicht
was wird man halt auch welt zu lang kein
bürger mehr beihilfen
verlange keine bürger mehr gegessen
neben letztens gordon ramsay ist aber
okay ich habe selbst mal das war kein
bürger das ist schon hart ist absolut
krank ist ein richtig guter parat das
ist manchmal habe ich so tage wo ich
auch so viel
protein bedarf nach dem bürger auf jeden
fall gedeckt ich glaube dass auf jeden
fall der alptraum von ihrem der ein
geschäftsessen hat oder auch einem date
ist aber ich würde sagen wir machen
weiter mit der nächsten sache weiter
geht es mit dem obligatorischen press
fest dass wir manchmal haben wenn wir
diese bestell videos drehen wir haben
die rahmen sieht erstmal super aus
riecht ein bisschen speziell also
aha ist übrigens
für mensch hat so einen tollen witz
gemacht willst ihn nicht geholt ich
meinte ich wollte gerne die
rahmenbedingungen ab
wie sieht denn die brühe außer dienst
bekannterweise das wichtigste
nicht verkehrt auschwitz einfach drauf
so wie gedacht uns auch sehr praktisch
habe er darum gebeten besteck mit
geliefert zu bekommen und ich hoffe dann
die sub mal mit den stäbchen wird es
doch besser sein
das neue blatt hat ein bisschen gelitten
unter der lieferung dass ich mehr so
knusprig und die nudeln müssen wir jetzt
auch erstmal wieder so ein bisschen zum
leben bekommen probiere das bringt
zwischenzeit mal paraden das chicken
sieht frittiert schon sehr krass aus
[Musik]
dass der stabile schön saftig frittiert
der uci drin knusprig nach oben wir uns
allerdings noch mal den preispunkt von
15 euro 90 in den kopf das ist schon
gefühlt nicht so viel was man wo kann
ich meinen charakter der bürger gerade
weil die bis teuer aber er war ja ultra
viel fleisch trinkt hier hat man so früh
nudeln im rahmen sind da ein bisschen
teurer
ich mag nicht so ultra gerne die bambus
note also von der geruch von dem bambus
ist auch geschmacklich irgendwie so ein
bisschen da du hast die brühe probiert
noch mal so für sich selbst
es hat auch eine gute rahmen brühe aber
nicht so cremig wie ich das von meinem
lieblings rahmen spot oder vom
krassesten wo ich immer war in
düsseldorf kenne kreis in einem nicht
verkehrt aber will ich für das geld
glaube ich nicht noch mal bestellen wenn
ich ehrlich bin ich weiß auch nicht ob
rahmen so wirklich das beste essen zu
bestellen und zwar irgendwie ist es ein
bisschen doof so du freust dich ja auch
darauf dass auch sogar traditionellen
schüssel zu essen so mit diesem keramik
löffeln und so und das so mit stäbchen
aus einem papier box zu essen ist
irgendwie ein bisschen befremdlich noch
für mich gerecht ist aber anders aus mit
dem letzten gericht dass wir haben unser
wiener schnitzel darum kümmere ich mich
jetzt und wir sehen uns in eine minute
die teuerste und finale bestellung des
tages 23 93 ist kein verkehrter preis
von wiener schnitzel und die preise
werden sind auch schon mal würdige
portionen gucken wir mal rein es ist auf
jeden fall ne ansage also es ist wie ich
schon vom foto gedacht hatte nicht so
ein klassisches wiener schnitzel so
sieht das ganze aus wir haben schnitzel
das so in die box reingepackt wurde
liegt auf dem kartoffelsalat
haben wir auf jeden fall verbessern kann
man verbessern dass das vieh verladen
kaum besser war ja wieder auch so liebte
konzept technisch kann man es ja machen
wir gucken uns das ganze land braucht
schneidet sich halt wirklich pro tonne
jemand check auf jeden fall das ist
wirklich ein echtes wiener schnitzel ist
von der kartoffelsalat auch nicht von
schlechten eltern der das schneidet sich
gerade mit seinem messer halt wirklich
wie verrückt ist aber echt ein punkt ist
von unten so ein bisschen aufweicht also
endlich mal anschaut bleibt die panade
natürlich nicht knusprig wenn man auf
dem karton verpackt das ist
geschmacklich safe geil ist das ist ja
ein geländer des ladens also ist der
laden schuld ist so einfach
wäre kampf kampf haben mit ihr andere
läden machen besser noch andere länder
uns besser 100% widersprochen mit dem
feedback zur schale reis glaube ich
eigentlich richtig gut sein können ich
glaube so für das wiener schnitzel den
kartoffelsalat und den beilagensalat
wünsche im restaurant 22 euro 90 zahl
aber so geliefert nicht also da braucht
zum besseres liefert konzept kann er uns
hat einfach unter der lieferung gelitten
und das ist schade eigentlich es geil
war das ding ist nicht dass es nicht
lecker ist wirst du es trotzdem noch
sehr lecker es ist aber vielleicht mit
23 9 slacker und das wissen dass es
keiner sein konnte was gut schmeckt halt
durch trotzdem gut sondern
hmm für den kartoffelsalat macht das gar
nichts mehr hat sich da wohl gefühlt in
der fassung der salat auch so ein
bisschen eingefallen und so gefühl dass
das schnitzel eigentlich geil wäre ja es
ist auch nicht schlimm es wirklich sehen
die fahrer umfangen bearbeiten ja ich
muss sagen mein heutiger favorit war
glaube ich der bürger aber alle drei
bestellungen sind eigentlich so dass man
wenn man das geld ausgibt wie beim
restaurant ist 224 euro für ein
schnitzel 19 euro firmen burger 16 euro
für rahmen so dann kauft man doch lieber
noch das erlebnis da hinzugehen mit
bestellen ist für mich häufig so ein
ding wirklich schneller gehen kann aber
es war trotzdem interessant wer weiß
vielleicht sind sie ja die günstigste
speisen beim lieferservice auch eine
erfahrung wert wir werden sehen dank
fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal und
macht's gut